from a guy's point of view right yeah
why why would we wait for marriage or
for long term with a girl that has given
it up for free before he shouldn't so
then how would how would that work right
because maybe like I don't know how long
you waited or what but like like she
slept with four other dudes no why would
a guy like wait for a girl that slept
now what I'm trying to say is that it's
not a matter of waiting right right it's
the matter of fact 4 or 18 for me it's
disgusting yeah I agree with you so what
she needs to do she needs to hold it
down so as she keep that four so as she
gets like bro 25 with that same four
then she can stop again right right
don't add any more to it because she's
got too much already right okay I agree
that's what I mean she can continue
after she reaches 25 because 24 at 25 is
all right yeah but you know what you
know what you know what happens is
though yeah is this
it stays at four and then usually
no no no but nobody check it check it
but then she'll meet some guy and say
her body counts 20 these times she meets
the guy and she will tell the guy it's
full
right now
the thing is yeah the world's big you
know I mean like you could go [__]
Manchester tomorrow meet some guys
you can't really like the world's big
the world's big you meet a girl in a bar
tomorrow you don't know where she's from
what end she's from you don't know you
don't know any of our backgrounds you've
got no you've got no mutual friends
you've got no mutual friends she's got
200 followers on Instagram on on private
do whatever you know what I mean like
you're not gonna know her background or
her past you know I mean she could tell
you anything so in reality nobody knows
really yeah there's hello Manda a wifey
girls right now the worst person
to live with if you really tell a big
big lie the worst person that you can
live with
have a really good brain to remember to
lie all the time or either that or she
were telling herself all right see what
you were telling herself she was able to
end up lying and getting her so caught
up or she will end up telling her nurses
I genuinely think like
okay if you're gonna be I think the
reason guys say that is because they're
not with girls that long anymore like
how many people have really I know I
think you said you an eight-year
relationship but that's not common right
like how many people are really together
long term 20 30 40 50 years if you're
with a girl for 50 years you think she
can keep that secret for 50 years you
don't think anything will come out you
don't think you'll run it I don't think
so especially you don't think her
friends might say something because her
friends are the ones that know okay so
so hold on one second here how much
woman yeah you know give men kids there
that's not theirs our men's are finding
out years and years later woman like
that seriously the wicked like that's
the thing that you guys should watch
it's called wicked Matrix of women's
I've give men kids that's not their kids
you're right you're right you're
absolutely
no no you're you're absolutely right
women can and do live my point is that
the truth usually comes out eventually
because because the thing is like if you
if you hoe around for too long you can't
run from yourself you can't you are who
you are you are are your habits so if
you have the habit of sleeping around
for 10 15 years like you're gonna you're
gonna go back to the streets eventually
your friends your friends are gonna slip
up like the the crazy stories you told
your friends someone's gonna say
something like you don't think like
girls talk and eventually [__] comes out
go ahead the thing is though they're
Extremes in it like if it goes you slept
with like 15 guys or whatever she meets
a guy she really likes tells him oh my
body counts for right she's not gonna
confess that she's really 15 and her
friends are not going to beat up because
it's not that much of a big deal because
like most guys like when I was when I
was dating like I was meeting girls
going on dates every single girl I met
said I've not had sex in three months oh
that's the one
every single time
all right
and for me I was like I've heard this so
many times so I know you're lying so I
mean but again
like if she adds 10 more to her body
count and by the time she's 25 26 meets
the one she can tell the guys 47. I
ain't gonna know I just I'm a big
believer and the truth comes out
eventually and someone's gonna say
something where you're like that doesn't
add up or what she said I think most
girls or you might meet someone that you
know that that it comes out that he
slept I just think eventually yeah go
ahead he had his hand up before okay go
ahead okay it doesn't it doesn't thank
you
now it doesn't always come out because
um I don't know if you like guys watch
stand-up Community uh comedy much like
Chris Rock said uh men tell the most
lies men lie the most women tell the
biggest lies and um a guy you know a guy
or girl can go throughout a whole whole
life you know when like uh
you know you know the woman will be
she'll lie and say oh but you know the
baby's yours and um
like it's harder in it like I don't
think you could get away with as much
nowadays especially nowadays yeah girls
want to be posted like it's a big thing
for a girl like so
whatever you ain't said once you get
posted especially if you're like
nowadays everyone's bait like a lot of
people are big okay so nowadays you get
posted you go out you got friends
everyone's connected by what four or
five periods like nowadays you might not
find out about every one of the body
count but you will find out about enough
where it's like yeah yeah all right you
get a chance
you post a new girl enough and then like
you can tell from the people
you'll see if she was at the clubs every
weekend five years ago I mean you're
gonna get a couple bodies
again for five years
yeah if if you tell the guy your body
count and he has an issue with it does
does that give you the ick I think it
does because why'd you care like also if
you ask them because I guarantee you
because I've talked to people about body
accounts before at the age of 18 now
there's so many guys that is double what
mine is like I think I thought yeah I
don't think it should matter because the
people that care the most are the ones
that trust they have so many more than
you okay no no guys guys what do you
think pal no I I think that it matters
it absolutely matters and every data you
look at the more the more guys you sleep
with the more likely you are to be
divorced really yeah and okay if you and
there's a couple different studies so
the numbers vary a little bit but one
there's one study where if you slept if
you're a virgin when you get married
you've been 80 chance of a happy
marriage in 10 years 80 and you know
what it drops to After Five Guys which
most men pray for nowadays 25 chance of
being happily married after 10 years so
and then people will you know there's
other studies that it's fifty percent
forty percent thirty percent of whatever
it is but the most happy tend to be the
virgins who's trying to marry a virgin
though really intriguous yeah
they've got no experience yeah that's
why I'm the teacher
that's a huge damaging someone from
and it might not be a virgin but most
guys most guys would prefer five over
50. yeah yeah I know we have to go to
the extremes to like to prove the point
because historically men had to give me
a virgin men had to ensure paternity so
they had to know am I am I passing on
resources to a kid that's mine because
historically we didn't have paternity
tests we didn't have DNA tests so the
only way they could decipher that is is
this woman pure how does she act how she
et cetera et cetera et cetera but you
know going back to it I I really don't
think that you can hide it for you can
only hide it for so I'm surprised how
many men are still not doing DNA tests
you know what I'm saying so there's a
lot of men are not doing them because
you know a man's told that's his kid
yeah
you see the thing is here you know me
too you see the things that Jamaican guy
said this he said listen any man could
have a kid you don't need to breed a
girl because a woman get pregnant and
tell you the kids is yours you don't
know if the kids did the woman said it's
yours and you're like yeah man you take
the kids I'm saying you don't have the
kids are we talking about Jamaican men
okay
you can't talk about yourself not
because we [__] you down you gave it
to us because my dad is Jamaican around
a lot of Jamaican men and I know a lot
of Jamaican men who have a bag of Pitney
yeah you know I might be a stater I know
what you mean I know a [__] yeah
Twitter you're getting on to me oh you
should have kids yeah I said what man I
got this much kids you had a pair of
twins twins swab them wasn't his but
that was it for a minute I see let's
bring moms back into this let's bring
moms back into this this is where moms
come in handy okay more often than not
your mom would be the first one that's
the DNA testing
your mom will tell you I don't know
about it I don't know about that one you
know you see the one that you don't want
to claim your mom will tell you listen
that one's one of yours yeah trust me
your mom's
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible